the prophet the great leader himself did
you know that Donald Trump means Herald
of the world ruler no yeah Donald Donna
it's Irish or something it's Scottish
Donald means World ruler or World
wielder okay and Trump means the the
trumpet sound the so it's it's
translates to like the announcement the
the the the the the the beckoning or the
you know the announcement of the world
ruler where do you know what Joe Biden
means
Donald Trump warns of possible World War
III Over Ukraine and Taiwan and it's
funny because we look at the story and
it's like oh wow Donald Trump is warning
over and it's like you know everyone's
kind of been saying that already so it's
a bit late to the party but I'm
wondering
um I guess what I'm wondering with this
story is yes especially with what we're
seeing with the sabotage and this
pipeline in Europe and with China firing
missiles over Taiwan we've never been
closer uh we've never been closer to a
major International Conflict at least in
our lifetimes I mean obviously we had
War but I'm saying like right now and so
I wonder though
are people going to see this two
questions what will this what impact
will all of this have on the midterms
are people going to hear what Trump is
saying and be like yes Joe Biden is
causing more war or he's a terrible
leader and he can't handle it we need
someone stronger
will this result in Republican Victory
or even a trump victory in 2024 what do
you
think
well unfortunately a lot of Republicans
are are
very gung-ho in sending Ukraine more
money and more money and more money and
it just it doesn't end we're just it's
this money printer Gober how much do you
need Vladimir you know I mean it's it's
ridiculous so uh so you're not going to
have the Republicans
campaigning off of that but if everybody
knew how much that we're sending over
there to prolong a war that could have
ended months ago or in fact probably
wouldn't have even started if Donald
Trump had still been president and had a
second term right I don't know about
that Trump did send lethal weapons to
Ukraine and did something that Obama
wouldn't even dare to do so Obama was
too scared to send lethal weapons but do
you think that Russia would have it's
hard it's very hard to say it's hard to
say but but I'll tell you what it didn't
it didn't happen when Trump was
President so we know that for a fact
well there's there's other escalations
especially in the dumbass region and the
Crimea region between Russia and the and
but not in the western not not to the
scale of course yeah no no now it's
tragic now the life loss the the
severity of the situation is is very big
so Trump trump kind of had a very
chaotic bombastic foreign policy it was
kind of uh he even described himself as
half nationalistic half globalist he
said that himself and I think that was
very fairly represented with a lot of
his actions which some people cheered on
and some people were like what in the
world are you doing stop it like with
Siri
or trying to start a war with Iran uh
again lots of ridiculousness that comes
there but but Tim you asked you know
will people listen to Donald Trump no
he's not on social media they can't
listen to him I heard Twitter's gonna
bring them back do you hear this uh
Facebook also said maybe they'll bring
him back they announced that they were
going to be looking at him he's truth
and but he's he's speaking to the echo
chamber he's speaking to his people that
are becoming isolated and people are
doubling down on of course hearing their
ideas regurgitated back to them rather
than of course having debates sparking
real conversations and actually engaging
the general public in conversations that
actually do matter and affect people and
are willing to challenge their beliefs
but what I what I mean is do you think
regular people are seeing what's going
on right now because of the war
escalation and being like Joe Biden's
not doing a good job well no because no
no try Trump is saying what he's saying
but the Republicans they're not they're
not going to go there because they're
for the war I'm talking about the people
in Congress I I like Republican
leaderships like like Kevin McCarthy uh
is is for it but you know you might have
you know Josh Hawley but he's not he's
not leadership he's not Republican
leadership so I'd say for I'd say the
majority of the Republican party right
now
they're they're talking about domestic
issues they're not they're they're not
they don't want to be like oh well
they're they're Russian you know they're
Russian uh uh sympathizers because they
want the war to stop in in Ukraine uh
but you just need to I I think a lot of
people I don't think that the majority
of Americans understand
that we shouldn't be there that we're
there under false pretenses and that
we're spending way too much money wow
that sounds familiar
you could like that's that that
describes American foreign policy for
the past 40 years yeah uh but we're it's
not it's not something that's gonna
turn the tide for Republicans this
pipeline stuff and Taiwan stuff could
people are going to be like hey I think
there needs to be I think there needs to
be well Taiwan I mean that's a whole
different story and Joe Biden saying oh
yeah we're gonna you know I've I've
never I don't think I've ever seen a
commander-in-chief say something
definitive as
um yeah if taiwan's attacked we're going
to use our troops and we're going to
defend them and then the White House
going uh no that our policy hasn't
changed it's not what he meant like I've
never four times and and this is this
has happened I've never seen a president
walked back so much if they're coming
like oh hey the pandemic's over and then
everybody in the administration's like
uh not really like no if he's wrong if
he's that he's the pr he's supposedly
the resident of the United States he
should actually be if his word should be
Bond if if he says something that's it
it shouldn't be I mean it just under
first of all if no matter what he says
he's being undermined he's being
undermined by his own people so that
makes him look wait that's what I'm
talking about and the same thing with
Taiwan I mean if if China wants to to uh
attack Taiwan do you think do you think
that they're going to take Biden at his
word or they're going to go with the
administration it's not going to do
anything do you know the news cycle that
was the Catalyst for Joe Biden's
approval writing going underwater yeah
Afghanistan boom and so you know I want
to believe that regular people aren't
don't care too much about foreign policy
but I think that shows that was huge the
failure of Joe Biden's foreign policy
made a huge impact um because it was the
biggest news story of the year I mean
everything was the whole that whole
thing was covered and I think if we
didn't lose the those 13 service members
it his approval rating he might have
been he might have been able to go you
know what we we got out sure we left a
bunch of stuff behind but we got out and
nobody died oh you know a bunch of
people died he bombed uh an aid worker
and he tried to blame as Isis K and it
wasn't even an I said K member it was
like yeah it's providing water to
Afghanistan yeah oh and and the New York
Times you know they did an amazing uh
wrap-up of of those events a great
article great video uh but the fact that
we just like droned a bunch of kids for
no reason for oh it's a uh it's an Isis
K analyst or something they're they're
uh what was the I forgot what it was it
was like some kind of like engineer or
something and then it it wasn't it was a
guy with putting water in the back of
his car you know and and nobody nobody
was held responsible that's the thing
that that kills me Joe Biden goes well
I'm going to take responsibility for if
I make a mistake and then uh with with
Afghanistan or you're gonna take
responsibility well there was weeks ago
it was just four or five weeks ago
people falling from that didn't happen
the borders secure well it's very low
right now like every nothing nothing is
his fault like like with the gas prices
he you know he's like I I released all
this stuff from the Strategic uh oil
petroleum Reserve I did it I lowered
those gas prices and and then they're
calling back up and he's like you gas
stations you need to you need to lower
your prices I'm stuck I'm price gouging
I'm beyond thinking any of this is a
coincidence well but with Afghanistan
nobody nobody was held responsible for
for that for that drone strike for for
for everything the the the terrible pull
out they're they're celebrating it
notice that that he was like oh I did it
I pulled him out it's like no Trump
trump said an emotion and there were
conditions and those conditions were not
met when we left
the Taliban was supposed to actually be
in uh in negotiations with the Afghan uh
government that was supposed to be
happening and it didn't and Biden pulled
out anyway because he wanted a photo op
on 9 11. no I think it was intentional I
think that that partly but I think it
was basically sabotage you don't you
don't fully Bagram without notifying the
the security forces unless you
intentionally want the Air Force Base
they're too busy trying to get their
troops to read anti-racist baby but but
will the will the voters remember this
in this upcoming midterm in the next
coming election I I I haven't seen a lot
of it a lot of people are not going to
be reminded of it I think social media
is hiding a lot of relative information
to this but when it comes to what's
happening right now I think that has
everyone's attention what's happening in
Ukraine what's happening with Russia is
on everyone's peer review everyone's
talking about this talking about it
everyone's talking about the possibility
of a nuclear war and according to a
Quincy poll 57 of U.S voters strongly or
somewhat support the U.S pursuing
diplomat negotiations as soon as
possible when it comes to the war in
Ukraine so that that's not really that
much of a strong number it's kind of 50
50 57 is not that much but the problem
is that the Biden Administration keeps
saying that we are not going that
officially we're not going to be part of
those negotiations that it has that it
that it all is on zelinski but that's
not true because the Western World
influences the negotiations but they
keep saying that that's what that that
but that's out of it but that's not true
that's what well that's their official
thing yeah yeah but that's not that's
not true at all because obviously this
is a proxy award this is a war between
major Global powers that are saying you
know what we're going to fight it out
we're going to fight it out here in
Ukraine just like they did in Syria just
like they did in many other places
around the world like Libya and we could
keep going on and on I mean it's been
going on for a long time yeah yeah
Vietnam Korea the the Cold War hasn't
really ended it's kind of prolonged here
with a lot of this kind of
neoconservative project for a new
American Think Tank policy that really
has taken over American foreign policy
ever since 2001.
at least it's been Go I mean 1946 really
the new with the world liberal economic
order they've been figuring out how to
create limited Wars all over Earth to
keep the war machine strong but to keep
nuclear bombs in the pocket so that
they're not used
yeah but but again when it comes to
what's happening domestically how how do
you think Americans uh since it's you
cover a lot of domestic stuff what what
where is foreign policy on the American
priority list according to from you know
all the research and all the stuff does
it come up is it even important or is it
is it an afterthought for the average
American I think the average American is
more worried about their pocketbook and
what's happening around the kitchen
table as Joe Biden says thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and we'll
see you all there